Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In the field of the Monulia was planted a garden, which burst forth and blossomed every day. It was sown with lilies. By the white and the red which budded and flowered were flesh and blood and weapons and the slosh of splattered brains. Spirits and souls, sinners and saved, the freshly killed replenished hell and paradise. We are joined by renowned historian Tom Holland, as always this week, talking about the Cathars. And Tom, that was from an anonymous troubadour, I think, talking about the Albigensian Crusade. by mark gregory peck in his book a most holy war
感谢收听《历史的 rest is history》。想要每周获取独家彩音、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在莫努利亚的土地上，曾长出一座花园，它每日绽放。花园里播种着百合。那含苞吐艳的红白百合，正是血肉、兵刃以及飞溅的脑浆。生灵与灵魂、罪人与得救者，新死之人的鲜血填满了地狱与天堂。本周，著名历史学家汤姆·霍兰德一如既往地做客我们的节目，与我们聊聊卡特尔派。汤姆，我想那段话出自一位匿名的游吟诗人，谈的是阿尔比十字军东征，出自马克·格雷戈里·佩格（Mark Gregory Pegg）的书《一场最神圣的战争》。
which is um a brilliant account of the subject of today's episode dominic yes albigensian crusade and its aftermath so to recap for those people who are coming to us fresh this is the third of um a mighty trilogy the first episode was about albino monks was about yes a man from doctor who um the creation of the da Vinci code conspiracy theory the idea of the cathars as the secret society part of this world including the templars and the priory of scion that protected the merovingian bloodline of jesus and mary magdalene in the second episode tom you talked us through the reality the historical reality what historians now think about the Cathars. Most. Not all, I think, but most.
这也是对今天这期节目主题的精彩阐述，多米尼克。是的，阿尔比十字军东征及其后续。因此，为新听众做个总结，这是宏大三部曲中的第三部。第一集讲的是阿尔比修士，讲的是《神秘博士》里的某个人，以及《达·芬奇密码》阴谋论的诞生——卡特尔派被视为秘密社团，是包括圣殿骑士团和锡安会等世界体系的一部分，他们保护着耶稣和抹大拉的玛丽亚的墨洛温王朝血脉。在第二集里，汤姆，你为我们剖析了现实，即历史的现实，也就是现在历史学家对卡特尔派的看法。大多数。我想并非全部，但绝大多数。
And their role as a sort of resistance was a holdout against the great revolution of the papacy within Christendom in what the 11th, 12th centuries, I suppose. And now we're into the action. We are. Because now there's going to be an awful lot of spattered brains in this story. And it's our first crusade on the show. So the crusades is a kind of obvious topic, isn't it? That we haven't actually touched till now. So we're plunging in with, you know, in many ways, the darkest, I think.
以及他们在基督教内部对抗教皇大革命时所充当的某种抵抗力量、据点，我想大概是在11、12世纪。现在我们进入行动阶段了。确实如此。因为接下来这个故事里会有大量飞溅的脑浆。这也是我们节目中第一次涉及十字军东征。所以十字军东征是一个显而易见的话题，对吧？直到现在我们其实都还没有涉及。所以我们要深入探讨，我认为，在许多方面这是最黑暗的一次。
Right. Because the most one-sided, I suppose, of the crusades. Do you think? I think because it looks forward to some of the darkest episodes in modern history okay um and perhaps talk about that at the end the way in which you know it's a very modern war right yeah but we maybe talk about that towards the end of the show so we ended the last episode and a real cliffhanger so that was the beginning of 1208 raymond of toulouse who's been going back and forth. He's accusing people
没错。因为我想，这是最失衡的一次十字军东征。你觉得呢？我认为是因为它预示着现代历史上一些最黑暗的时期。好吧，也许我们可以在最后谈谈这一点，它所呈现的那种非常现代的战争，对吧？是的，但我们可能会在节目快结束时讨论这一点。所以我们上一集在真正的悬念中结束了。那是1208年初，图卢兹伯爵雷蒙德一直摇摆不定。他指责别人
of being heretics, but he's also been trying to resist attempts to cleanse his territory of heresy. He's had this unsuccessful meeting with the papal emissary, who then unfortunately has been murdered by a knight the very next day. And so, Tom, what happens next? So Innocent III, the the great pope perhaps the most powerful pope who who has ever ruled he's furious and he blames raymond and sees that raymond the country blues is in associate you know he's he's in the clutches of of all these heretics that he thinks are teeming everywhere in the region so he he wants the heresy cleaned up and so he he does what he's been doing for several years and he turns to to the king of France, Philip Augustus II, who is distracted.
是异端，但他也一直在试图抵制清除其领地上异端的企图。他与教皇使节进行了一场没有结果的会谈，而不幸的是，这位使节第二天就被一名骑士谋杀了。那么，汤姆，接下来发生了什么？因此，英诺森三世——这位伟大的教皇，也许是统治过教皇中最具权力的一位——勃然大怒。他指责雷蒙德，认为图卢兹的雷蒙德与那些异端同流合污，他觉得异端在这个地区到处泛滥。所以他想要彻底清除异端，于是他做了他几年来一直在做的事：他转向法兰克国王菲利普·奥古斯都二世，但菲利普分身乏术。
He's facing invasion by John, the king of England. He's got the Holy Roman Emperor as well, and he can't be bothered. He doesn't want to get distracted with all this nonsense down in the south. And so he refuses. And Innocent, he's had enough. If the king won't go, then Innocent is going to conjure up his own army. And he does it in the way that popes have been conjuring up armies to fight against the enemies of Christ since the end of the 11th century, which is to summon them to an armed pilgrimage. Now, we know these armed pilgrimages
他正面临英格兰国王约翰的入侵，他还有神圣罗马帝国皇帝的威胁，根本无暇分身。他不想被南方这些无聊的破事分散精力。因此他拒绝了。英诺森已经忍无可忍。既然国王不肯出兵，那英诺森就要自己召集军队。他采取了自11世纪末以来教皇们用来对抗基督敌人的方法，那就是召唤他们进行武装朝圣。现在，我们把这些武装朝圣
as crusades, but this is a word that doesn't start to be used until this period. And it derives from the idea that you sign yourself with the cross. So cruci signati. And preachers go out throughout the winter of 1208 and 1209, summoning men from across not just France, but the whole of Christendom, to take up the cross. So a preacher says, the cross that is fixed to your coats with a soft thread was fixed to Christ's flesh with iron nails. In other words, that by putting on the cross, in some way they are imitating Christ, and that this armed pilgrimage offers warriors the chance to live as Christ lived, so that the warfare, the slaughter that they will bring is sanctified. It's holy. It's doing God's purpose, and it's emulating Christ. And Pegg,
称为十字军东征，但这个词直到这一时期才开始被使用。它源于人们在身上缝上十字标志的做法。也就是所谓的“十字军”。1208年和1209年的整个冬天，传教士们四处奔走，号召不仅来自法兰克，而且来自整个基督教世界的男人们加入十字军。因此一位传教士说，用软线固定在你们大衣上的十字架，是用铁钉固定在基督肉体上的。换句话说，通过佩戴十字架，他们在某种程度上是在模仿基督，这场武装朝圣为勇士们提供了像基督那样生活的机会，这样他们带来的战争和屠杀就被赋予了神圣的意义。它是神圣的。它是在执行上帝的旨意，是在效仿基督。而佩格
in his book, describes this as an absolutely fateful moment, that it's the merging, he says, of a century or more of Latin Christian thought on heresy and holy war. So, you know, these are traditions traditions the idea of holy war the idea that there are there are heretics everywhere these are traditions that that have kind of been emerged from the great papal revolution of the 11th century and they've been moving in parallel throughout the 12th century yeah and now under innocent the third they're being joined and you know this is an incredibly fateful moment. And Innocent sees it as potentially apocalyptic, that if heresy is not destroyed, then it is more dangerous than, say, the Saracens,
在他的书中将此描述为一个绝对决定命运的时刻，他说，这是拉丁基督教关于异端和圣战一个多或更多世纪思想的融合。所以，你知道，这些传统——圣战的思想、到处都有异端的思想——这些传统是从11世纪伟大的教皇革命中涌现出来的，并且在整个12世纪并行发展。而现在，在英诺森三世的领导下，它们被结合在了一起，你知道，这是一个极其命运攸关的时刻。在英诺森看来，这具有潜在的末日色彩，如果异端不被消灭，那么它的危险性甚至比萨拉森人还要大，
because it's a sickness within the body of Christendom itself. And is this, Tom, the first great example of this idea of fighting a holy war against the enemy within? I mean, that's something we're so familiar with now. You know, the real enemies are within your house. You know, they're not the Muslims or whoever it might be. They are other Christians. Exactly. And so that is why the heretics are so dangerous is that, you know, if you allow them to live, then you might become a heretic. It's kind of like a zombie plague. You know, if you allow the zombies to spread, then you yourself will become a zombie. The real enemies are not the capitalists, they're the Trotskyites or whatever. That's what it foreshadows, isn't it? Yeah, I suppose. And in the episode we did
因为它就像是基督教躯体内部的毒瘤。汤姆，这是不是这种针对内部敌人发动圣战理念的第一个伟大例证？我的意思是，这是我们现在非常熟悉的事情。你知道，真正的敌人就在你的屋檐下。你知道，他们不是穆斯林或其他什么人。他们是其他基督徒。正是如此。这就是为什么异端如此危险，因为如果你让他们活着，那么你自己也可能会变成异端。这有点像僵尸瘟疫。你知道，如果你让僵尸蔓延开来，你自己也会变成僵尸。真正的敌人不是资本主义者，而是托洛茨基分子之类的。这就是它的预示，对吧？是的，我想是这样的。在关于纳粹的那期节目里，
on the Nazis, we were talking about how anti-Semites see the Jews as a kind of disease. And that's pretty much what Innocent III is seeing heretics as. And he feels that unless the heretics are destroyed, then their infection will spread and corrupt the entire body of Christendom. And everything that the church exists to do to bring the Christian people to God is in the balance. So in that sense, the stakes couldn't be higher. It is a war with cosmic resonance. So this is the language that is being used. This is the background to this kind of drumbeat of warriors from across Europe, starting to mass and head down in the early months of 1209 towards the south of France. Meanwhile, you can imagine that
我们谈到了反犹太主义者如何将犹太人视为一种疾病。这正是英诺森三世看待异端的方式。他觉得，如果不消灭异端，它们的感染就会蔓延并腐蚀整个基督教躯体。而教会存在的一切目的——将基督教人民引向上帝——都危在卵翼。从这个意义上说，赌注之高无以复加。这是一场具有宇宙共鸣的战争。这就是当时使用的语言。这就是欧洲各地勇士们开始集结并在1209年初向法国南部进发的背景。与此同时，你可以想象
Raymond VI, the Count of Toulouse, who's kind of in the eye of the storm he spends all this period absolutely crapping himself a technical term tom yeah but accurate and so he is sending endless kind of messages to rome kind of saying it's fine you know i'll do whatever you want please stop it um and um as the uh as the army start to kind of mass in uh in 1209 basically he he completely surrenders and it's all very game of thrones because he he's an excommunicate and so to be welcomed back into the fold of the church he's made to walk naked all right through the streets of st gilles where he'd be negotiating with the the papal emissary who then gets killed so in a way he's kind of accepting responsibility for the murder of that emissary even though almost almost certainly, you know, he had nothing to do with it.
第六代图卢兹伯爵雷蒙德，他正处于风暴中心，这段时间他吓得屁滚尿流——这是个专业术语吧，汤姆？是的，但很准确。因此他不断向罗马发送各种信息，说什么“这很好，你知道的，我会按你们的要求做，请停下来吧”，而随着军队在1209年开始集结，基本上他彻底投降了，这一切非常像《权力的游戏》，因为他是个被逐出教会的人，为了重新被接纳回教会，他被强迫赤身裸体穿过圣吉尔的街道——也就是他曾经与后来被杀害的教皇使节谈判的地方。所以从某种意义上说，他是在为那位使节的谋杀承担责任，尽管几乎可以肯定，这与他毫无关系。
And so he's led through the streets. He goes into the great church, the Shrine of Saint-Gilles. He swears repentance. He is flogged by the papal envoy. He's given a kind of coarse robe like Christ wore. So Christ was scourged, given a coarse robe. And then he is accepted back into the fold of the church and shortly afterwards in a brilliant move um raymond announces that he is joining the crusade
于是他被引领穿过街道。他走进大教堂，即圣吉尔圣殿。他发誓忏悔。他遭到教皇特使的鞭笞。他被授予一件像基督穿的那样粗糙的长袍——就像基督曾遭受鞭笞并被穿上粗糙的长袍一样。然后他重新被接纳回教会，不久之后，在一个精妙的举动中，雷蒙德宣布他加入了十字军。
yeah you know if you can't beat them join them so raymond is the sort of poacher turned gamekeeper par excellence but he's turning on his own people there is he tom yeah but he's you know you got to do what you got to do um yeah i mean you know you've got to do what you've got to do. Yeah, I mean, you've got what is effectively the largest army that's ever been seen, you know, assembled in France on your doorstep. They're coming for you. I think it's understandable. It's not heroic, but it's understandable. And actually, even before Raymond does his, you know, walk of shame, the killing has actually already begun. So you have a band of crusaders who turn out of a place called Casanoi, which is kind of just south of the Dordogne.
是的，你知道，打不过就加入。所以雷蒙德堪称从偷猎者转变为护林员的典范，但他这是在背叛自己的人民，对吧，汤姆？是的，但是，你该怎么做就得怎么做。是的，我的意思是，你该怎么做就得怎么做。是的，我的意思是，在你的家门口，集结了法兰克历史上规模空前庞大的军队。他们是冲着你来的。我认为这是可以理解的。这并不英勇，但可以理解。事实上，甚至在雷蒙德进行“耻辱之行”之前，杀戮就已经开始了。有一支十字军从一个叫卡萨诺伊（Casanoi）的地方杀出，该地位于多尔多涅河以南，
So on the kind of the northern flank of this region. Yeah. And Casanoi gets captured by the crusaders and they round up people who they condemn as heretics and they burn them. And there's a poem written about this whole crusade and it has the lines, the many fair women thrown into the flames for they refused to recant however much they were begged to do so. And what would they be recanting though? So this is the thing is that as the crusaders come with their desire to target heretics, so the people who are being condemned of heresy come to see the crusaders come with their desire to target heretics, so the people who are being condemned of heresy come to see the crusaders as an enemy and therefore to hold on to their
也就是该地区的北部边缘。卡萨诺伊被十字军攻陷，他们把被指控为异端的人集中起来并将他们烧死。有一首关于这次十字军东征的长诗，其中有这样几句：“许多美丽的妇女被投入烈火之中，因为她们无论如何哀求也拒绝叛教。”然而，她们到底要叛教什么呢？这就是关键所在：当十字军带着清除异端的渴望而来时，被指控为异端的人们也开始将十字军视为敌人，从而更加教条地坚守他们自己的立场。
own positions all the more dogmatically. And, you know, they are ready to die for it rather than to submit. But specifically what? In other words, there I am, I'm in Casanoi, I'm going to imagine myself a butcher and I'm being dragged, or I'm going to imagine myself a butcher, and I'm being dragged, or I'm going to imagine myself a fair maiden. I'm being dragged to the pyre. I'm sure listeners will enjoy this image. I'm being dragged to the pyre, there I am. And then people say, recant, or we will burn you, or whatever. What could I recant? What do I believe? So that is a really interesting question. I mean, we talked about aspects of it in the previous episode, this idea that the representatives of the kind of the papal establishment are outsiders, are aliens, are the heretics themselves, that the structures that govern the rhythms of Christian life in this region are seen by those who cleave to them as much holier, much more authentically Christian than that of the Crusaders. And I think there's indisputably over the course of this war, you know, as wars always do, it entrenches a sense of division. But you're right that the readiness of people in the region
而且，比起屈服，他们更愿意为此去死。但具体是什么呢？换句话说，假设我在卡萨诺伊，我把自己想象成一个屠夫，正被拖走……或者我把自己想象成一个美丽的少女，我正被拖上火刑柱。我相信听众会喜欢这个画面。我正被拖上火刑柱，我站在那里。然后人们说：“叛教，否则我们烧死你”或者诸如此类的话。我能叛教什么？我信仰什么？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我的意思是我们在上一集中讨论过它的某些方面，即教皇体制的代表被视为外来者、异星人、异端本身，而在这个地区支配着基督教生活节奏的那些结构，在那些笃信它们的人看来，要比十字军的信仰神圣得多、纯正得多。我认为毫无疑问，在这场战争的过程中——正如战争一贯做的那样——它加剧了分裂感。但你说得对，该地区人民准备好承受殉道的心态是非常非常惊人的。我想也许我们应该在稍后审视战争结束时发生的事情，以及这种异端——如果你想这样称呼的话——在多大程度上得以幸存、延续并转化。因为这其中可怕的一个方面——而且本意就是为了制造恐怖——是烧死异端的行为被有意地当作一种大屠杀，
to suffer martyrdom is really, really striking. And I think that perhaps we should look at that later on when we look at what happens when the war is over and the degree to which this heresy, if you want to call that uh survives and endures and transforms because one of the aspects of this that is horrifying and meant to be horrifying is that the burning of heretics is consciously offered up as a kind of holocaust um burnt offerings to the lord you know they are this is meant to be seen as something that is kind of simultaneously horrible and joyous and that i think is is what is so unsettling and shocking about the whole process and was clearly unsettling to contemporaries as well right and that that that
遭受殉道真的非常、非常震撼。我想或许我们应该在稍后探讨，当战争结束时会发生什么，以及这种异端——如果你愿意这样称呼的话——在多大程度上得以幸存、延续并发生转变，因为这件事最骇人听闻的方面之一（而且本来就是要达到骇人听闻的效果）是，烧死异端被刻意呈现为一种大屠杀，嗯，献给上帝的燔祭，你知道的，他们这样做，是希望这被视为一件既令人毛骨悚然又同时充满狂喜的事，而我认为，正是这一点让整个过程如此令人不安和震惊，显然，当时的人们也同样感到不安，对吧？而且，那，那，那
burning in um in casanoi is merely the precursor for the most famous and notorious Holocaust of the lot, which is the great town of Béziers, which is one of the two cities of Toulouse. And the vicomte of Béziers and Carcassonne in this period is a guy called Raymond Roger. And he is both the nephew and the rival of Raymond, the Count of Toulouse. So they kind of, you know, they're related, but they hate each other in the best traditions of medieval, medieval lords. And this is why Raymond VI, who has, you know, repented, recanted, been welcomed back into the church and become a crusader, when he approaches Arnold Amalrec, the abbot of Citeaux, who is serving as the papal representative with this huge army, he turns up and he says, I think you should go to Vizier. So, in other words, target the city of his greatest rival. Yes. And Raymond Roger, who's only 24 and hasn't really been keeping track of what's been going on, is suddenly informed that the greatest Christian army ever, as it's being described, is coming towards him. He summons all the people of Béziers to a meeting and he says, guys, you're on your own. And then he scrams and heads off and kind of hunkers down in Carcassonne.
在卡萨诺伊的焚烧，仅仅是那场最著名、最臭名昭著的大屠杀的前奏，那就是贝济耶大镇，它是图卢兹的两大城市之一。在这段时期，贝济耶和卡尔卡松的子爵是一个名叫雷蒙·罗杰的人。他是图卢兹伯爵雷蒙的侄子兼死敌。所以他们算是，你知道的，他们有亲戚关系，但却按照中世纪领主的光荣传统，彼此恨之入骨。这就是为什么雷蒙六世——他已经，你知道的，忏悔过、改过自新、重新被教会接纳并成为了一名十字军战士——当他接近西托修道院的院长阿诺德·阿马尔里克（他作为教皇代表带着这支庞大军队出征）时，他走过去说道：“我认为你应该去贝济耶。”换句话说，把目标对准他最大死敌的城市。是的。而雷蒙·罗杰年仅24岁，根本没怎么关注外界发生的事情，突然接到通知说史上最伟大的基督教军队（正如人们所描述的那样）正朝他压境。他召集了贝济耶的所有居民开会，对他们说：“伙计们，你们自求多福吧。”然后他就溜之大吉，直奔卡尔卡松固守去了。
And the people in Bézier think, oh, God. And the whole story is tragic and comic in equal measure because the crusading army camps down in front of the walls of Bézier. Bézier has very, very strong fortifications. The people in Bézier think they're absolutely fine. Nothing, you know, they're not going to be stormed. And kind of various lads, they go out onto the bridge and they start kind of jeering at the crusaders and saying you know you're never going to get us and kind of you know running out sneering at them and then
贝济耶的人民心想：“天哪。”这个故事在悲剧和喜剧的成分上可以说是各占一半，因为十字军大营就在贝济耶的城墙外扎了下来。贝济耶有着非常、非常坚固的防御工事。贝济耶的人民觉得自己绝对安全。没什么好怕的，你知道的，他们觉得城池绝不会被攻陷。然后各种小伙子跑到桥上，开始对十字军冷嘲热讽，说：“你们永远也抓不到我们！”一边跑一边冲他们做鬼脸，然后
running back in and there's a whole gang of lads who are accompanying the crusaders so they are described as ribald boys but i suppose you, you know, if you're in Liverpool, you might call them scallies, I guess. It's that kind of thing. You know, they're kind of lads who are camp followers. But, you know, they've got a bit of... They fancy a fight. They fancy a fight.
跑回城里。有一帮年轻人跟着十字军一起来的，他们被描述为无赖少年，但我想，你要是在利物浦，可能会管他们叫小流氓吧，我猜。差不多就是那种类型。你知道的，他们就是那种随军的乌合之众。不过，你知道，他们有点……他们手痒想打一仗。他们很想打一仗。
And basically, they're not having this stuff, you know, all the lads in Bézier. So they follow it and they get into a punch-up and the punch-up then develops and they start piling in. And before they know it, they've captured Bé up and the punch up then develops and they part they start piling in and before they know it they've captured beziere and all the knights kind of look up and go oh and so they pile in and the slaughter proceeds so pegging in a most holy war has i mean the orb slowly darkened as rivulets of gore spilled down the streets and washed off the bridge sounds like one of my children's books tom yes absolutely and um inevitably the city is put to the torch because the idea of the holocaust is very important it has to be offered up as a burnt offering
基本上，他们可受不了这个，你知道的，贝济耶的那帮小伙子也是。所以他们跟着冲了出去，然后双方打了一架，接着这场斗殴进一步升级，更多人开始蜂拥而上。在他们还没反应过来之前，他们就已经攻占了——打了一架然后斗殴升级，他们一拥而上，回过神时已经占领了贝济耶，所有的骑士都抬起头来“哦”了一声，于是他们也一拥而上，大屠杀开始了。因此，在一场最神圣的战争中突进，我的意思是，随着细流般的血水顺着街道流淌并冲刷着桥梁，地平线慢慢变暗了。听起来就像我读给孩子听的故事书，汤姆。是的，完全是这样。而且，嗯，不可避免地，这座城市被付之一炬，因为大屠杀的理念非常重要，它必须作为燔祭被供奉上去。
and people in beziers have have um have gathered in the great church in beziers and we have a figure that 7 000 are incinerated there so there's um there's there's a book by uh a scholar called lawrence marvin which is very much focused not on the kind of the religious dimension of it but the military yeah he points out that um this figure couldn't possibly be true because as many observers including myself have concluded the church is simply not large enough to accommodate that many people oh so so that's a yeah you know that's that's an apt point he's a fun hating historian i think it's the but but but the point is that the incineration encourages these kind of stories because it's designed to be absolutely shocking you know this
贝济耶的人民都聚集在贝济耶的大教堂里，我们有一个数字显示有七千人在那里被烧死。所以，有一个学者叫劳伦斯·马尔文，他写过一本书，这本书的重点其实不是宗教维度，而是军事维度。是的，他指出这个数字绝不可能属实，因为正如包括我在内的许多观察家所断言的那样，教堂根本没有那么大，容纳不下那么多人。哦，所以这是一个，你知道的，一个切中要害的观点。他是个讨人厌的历史学家，我想这就是……但是，但是，重点在于，这种焚烧煽动了这类故事，因为它的目的就是为了绝对震撼人心，你知道的，这
is a burnt offering to the lord and the news of it reverberates across christendom it's an absolutely pointed display of divine vengeance that's that's what it's meant to be and um a decade after it perhaps the most famous saying that emerges from the albigensian crusade is attributed to arnold amalric who is the the papal envoy and this when the crusaders bursting into Béziers, and they can't distinguish between heretics and non-heretics, and one of them asks Amalric, well, you know, what do we do? How can we tell them apart? And the abbot replies, kill them, truly God will know his enemy. And whether he says that or not, it gets taken up and repeated because it articulates something very, very important, that the need to scour the region of heresy is more important than allowing the innocent to survive. So better ten innocent men are killed than one guilty man go free, basically.
是对主的一场燔祭，关于它的消息在整个基督教世界广为流传。这是一场绝对直白的神圣复仇展示，这正是它的用意所在。而且，大约十年后，阿尔比十字军东征中最著名的那句名言，被归功于教皇特使阿诺德·阿马尔里克。当时十字军冲进贝济耶，无法分辨异端和非异端，其中一人问阿马尔里克：“好吧，你知道的，我们该怎么做？我们怎么把他们区分开来？”修道院院长回答说：“杀光他们，上帝自然会认出自己的敌人。”不管他有没有说过这话，这句话都被采纳并广为流传，因为它阐明了一个非常、非常重要的道理：清除该地区的异端的必要性，远比允许无辜者存活更重要。所以基本上就是，宁可错杀十个无辜，绝不放过一个有罪的人。
And so Amalric writes to the Pope and he says that in Béziers, where thousands of people have been slaughtered or incinerated he says divine vengeance raged marvelously crikey that's um not quite turning the other cheek is it no but you know but but it is seen as the crusaders feel that they are imitating christ in doing this that this is what christ wants that this is what he would do so it's very it's kind of very sanguinary and weird and and terrifying and understandably everyone in carcassonne yeah you know i mean they're again to use the technical term crapping themselves um and the crusaders put carcassonne under siege for three weeks um after this period raymond roger decides i've had enough and he he opens negotiations inhabitants are allowed to leave wearing only
因此，阿马尔里克写信给教皇，他在信中说，在贝济耶，成千上万的人被屠杀或烧死，他写道：“神圣的复仇奇迹般地肆虐。”哎呀，这可真……不太像是“打左脸把右脸也伸过去”，对吧？没错，但是你知道，但它被视为十字军觉得自己这样做是在效仿基督，这就是基督想要的，这就是基督会做的事。所以这非常、非常血腥、诡异且骇人听闻，可以理解的是，卡尔卡松的每个人，是的，你知道的——用专业术语来说就是吓得屁滚尿流。十字军对卡尔卡松实施了长达三周的围城。在这段时期之后，雷蒙·罗杰决定：“我受够了。”他开启了谈判，城内居民被允许离开，但只能穿着
their shirts and so they do so all of them do they get to wear trousers nope just shirts apparently quite no trousers the people of this region are notorious for the uh the bright yellow tightness of their leggings so perhaps they're wearing those i don't know ungodly tom very ungodly but poor old raymond roger himself is taken captive despite the fact that he'd been given a promise of safe passage he's chained up and he dies three months later. So he is out of the way. And so the question now is who is going to become the new lord of Béziers and Carcassonne? And there are kind of various lords from the north of France who have turned up and they all think, actually, you know, this is a hiding for nothing.
内衣。于是他们照做了，所有人都是如此。他们能穿裤子吗？不，显然只有衬衣，完全没有裤子。这个地区的居民以穿着紧身亮黄色打底裤而臭名昭著，所以也许他们穿着那些，我不知道。这太不虔诚了，汤姆，非常不虔诚。但是可怜的老雷蒙·罗杰本人却被俘虏了，尽管此前曾有人承诺保证他的安全通行。他被戴上了脚镣，并在三个月后死去。所以他算是出局了。现在的问题是，谁将成为贝济耶和卡尔卡松的新领主？有各种来自法国北部的领主赶到了这里，他们都觉得，实际上，这是一场吃力不讨好的买卖。
Because the crusaders are, you know, their vow is to fight for 40 days and the 40 days are up. And so the likelihood is that large numbers are going to go away. So whoever is left in Béziers and Carcassonne is going to be surrounded by a very hostile population and not have many men. So they're all a bit nervous. So they say no. But then one of the northern lords says that he will do it. And he is a man in his mid 40s. He's from the vicinity of Paris.
因为十字军的誓言是战斗40天，而这40天已经期满。所以很有可能会有大批人离开。因此，无论谁留在贝济耶和卡尔卡松，都将被充满敌意的人口包围，而且兵力单薄。所以他们都有些紧张。于是他们都拒绝了。但随后，其中一位北方领主表示他愿意承担此事。他是一个四十岁左右的男子，来自巴黎附近。
He's also the Earl of Leicester. And he is a man called Simon de Montfort. To British listeners, Simon de Montfort, his son, you know, he's the guy who's associated with the founding of Parliament. The father of democracy. The father of democracy. democracy but simon de montfort his dad is a man who is very very devout possessed of a sense of his absolute holiness very very brilliant superb soldier and unbelievably brutal yeah and when the vast mass of the crusaders leave after the capture of carcassonne he's left with perhaps 100 knights few more i mean not you know very small number. And he's got
他也是莱斯特伯爵。他叫西蒙·德·蒙福尔。对于英国听众来说，西蒙·德·蒙福尔，他的儿子，你知道的，就是那个与议会创立联系在一起的人。民主之父。民主之父。民主，但是西蒙·德·蒙福尔，他的父亲是一个非常、非常虔诚的人，拥有绝对神圣的使命感，非常聪明、出色的士兵，而且极其残暴。是的，当卡尔卡松陷落后，庞大的十字军主力大批离去时，他身边大概只剩下一百名骑士，或者稍微多一点，我的意思是，数量非常少。而且他拥有
Carcassonne, which is a huge centre. He's got this kind of smouldering remains of Bézier. How's he going to hold it? And what he does is, year in, year out, crusaders will come and join him over the course of the summer. And then in the winter, they'll go. And the kind of ebb and flow of de Montfort's success and the ability of his opponents to recapture strongholds that he's captured just keeps on going on and so more and more of the region gets torched gets burnt fields get destroyed towns get demolished strongholds get toppled and it's absolutely hideous and it goes on year after year after year and so the cycle of war develops particular characteristics that make this crusade kind of notorious across christendom so the first
卡尔卡松，这是一个巨大的中心。他还拥有贝济耶那些尚在冒烟的废墟。他要怎么守住这里？他的做法是，年复一年，十字军会在夏天时前来加入他。然后到了冬天，他们就会离开。德·蒙福尔的成功经历着起起落落，他的对手重新夺回他所占领据点的能力也在持续不断地发生，因此该地区的越来越多的地方被付之一炬、被烧毁，田野被毁，城镇被摧毁，据点被推翻，这绝对是骇人听闻的，而且年复一年地持续下去。因此，战争的循环形成了独特的特征，使这场十字军东征在整个基督教世界声名狼藉。所以，第一点
is the tradition of the holocaust continues so in 1209 the first fort that he captures a place called cast he makes a point of watching the first two people to be burnt right you know he's he's making a statement and then the following year in july 12 10 um simon and his men capture a place called minerve oh yeah i've been there yes it's a very very impregnable site it's kind of one of those craggy rocky places that tourists you know immediately kind of conjures up a sense of the savagery and the romance of the time. But I mean, there's very little romance actually about his story because it falls after six weeks. Arnold Amalric turns up just as the surrender is being negotiated. And because he's a man of God, he feels obliged to offer everybody inside the town a pardon.
是焚烧的传统得以延续，所以在1209年，他攻占的第一座堡垒——一个叫做卡斯特的地方，他特意观看了头两个人被烧死，你知道的，他这是在表明态度。然后在第二年，即1210年7月，西蒙和他的手下攻占了一个叫做米内尔V的地方。哦，是的，我去过那儿。是的，那是一个极其易守难攻的地方，那种陡峭的岩石地带，游客们一看到就会立刻联想到那个时代的野蛮与浪漫。但我的意思是，关于他的故事其实没什么浪漫可言，因为这座城在抵抗了六周后陷落了。就在投降条款正在协商之际，阿诺德·阿马尔里克赶到了。由于他是一个神职人员，他觉得有义务向城内的每个人提供特赦。
And one of the crusaders says, well, what's this about? We want to burn them. And Amalric says, don't worry, I can guarantee you that it'll be fine because loads of them will not accept the pardon. And so 140 of the people of Minerva are burned. And it is reported that they were so hardened in their wickedness that they hurled themselves into the flames of their own accord. So again, this idea of the heretics willingly embracing the flame and you get a kind of detail that's almost kind of reminiscent of the episode that we did on the holocaust that afterwards the corpses have to be buried in mud because the stench of charred flesh is so revolting that crusaders who've just arrived just keep retching and vomiting 12 11 a place called lavar is captured
其中一个十字军战士说：“这算怎么回事？我们想烧死他们。”阿马尔里克说：“别担心，我向你们保证，这绝对没问题，因为他们当中有很多人不会接受特赦。”于是，米内尔的140名居民被烧死了。据报道，他们顽固至极，竟然主动跳进烈火之中。所以，再次出现了这种异端分子自愿拥抱火焰的想法，你还会听到一个细节，几乎让人联想到我们做过的那期关于大屠杀的节目，事后尸体必须埋在泥土里，因为烧焦的肉散发出的恶臭实在太令人作呕，以至于刚到达的十字军战士一直在作呕和呕吐。1211年，一个叫拉瓦尔的地方被攻陷
400 heretics are burned alive and again this is done with kind of a sense of joy. So it's coming genti gaudio, the phrase is the Latin phrase, with great joy. And at Lavar, the lady of the city who is not herself a heretic, but is accused of having been favorable to the heretics, she's thrown down a well and the crusaders hurls rocks onto her until she's crushed. You've used the word heretics a lot to describe the people who are being executed or the people who are being accused. And is it fair to say this is irrespective of their heretics is just the label that is being pinned on them because they are the local people of the who are on the wrong side? No, I think they are people who do hold opinions that would be defined.
400名异端被活活烧死，同样，这伴随着一种狂喜的感觉。拉丁语短语是“Cum ingenti gaudio”，意为带着极大的喜悦。在拉瓦尔，城里的女领主——她本人并非异端，但被指控曾对异端抱有好感——被扔进了一口井里，十字军向她砸石头，直到她被压死。你用了“异端”这个词很多次来描述那些被处决或被指控的人。那么，可不可以这样说，这与他们是否真的是异端无关，“异端”只是贴在他们身上的标签，因为他们是站在错误一方的当地人？不，我认为他们确实持有会被界定的观点。
I think so, yes. And we'll talk about exactly how these opinions may have evolved over the course of the crusade in the second half when we look at what happens in the aftermath of the war. But just to continue with the kind of the sense of the horrors of it, you have, as well as Holocaust, you have calculated atrocities. So, you know, garrisons will be captured. De Montfort will cut off, will will mutilate them cut off the noses you know gouge out the eyes and it's happening the other way around as well so if i don't know monks have been captured they'll be murdered uh de montfort's knights if they get captured there's a kind of a horrible story about them um you know they have their eyes gouged out and they're sent out into the winter to stumble their way back to carcassonne. And occasionally there are battles and campaigns in the open. And one of them is against the King of Aragon, who is coming to try and get rid of
我也这么认为。我们将在下半场探讨这些观点在十字军东征过程中是如何演变的，届时我们将看看战争结束后发生了什么。但为了继续讲述那种恐怖感，除了大屠杀，你还会看到有计划的暴行。所以，你知道的，驻军会被俘虏。德·蒙福尔会割掉他们的鼻子、挖出他们的眼睛进行残害，而且情况也会反过来发生——如果，我不知道，僧侣被俘虏了，他们就会被谋杀；如果德·蒙福尔的骑士被俘虏了，就会有一个关于他们的可怕故事，你知道的，他们的眼睛被挖出来，然后被赶到冬天的寒风中，跌跌撞撞地摸索着返回卡尔卡松。偶尔也会有公开的战斗和战役。其中一场是对阵阿拉贡国王，他前来试图除掉
Simon de Montfort and lay claim to this region himself. And he gets killed in a great battle at a place called Muret. So this sense of slaughter and horror is kind of escalating. But by and large, people across Christendom are seeing it as a kind of salutary demonstration of the power of christ so peg begins his his book a most holy war with this incredible description of one of the um the first ghosts to appear from purgatory it's a small boy who appears to a small girl um and he and he says he assures this girl that nothing has pleased god so much as the death and extermination of the aligensians. And the Albigensians is the word that's being used for the heretics of the region, the Albigois. And so it just goes on and on like this for kind of 20 years, endless slaughter, endless burning of fields, until finally, in 1218, you get this kind of deadlock between simon de montfort and raymond the sixth who is holed up in toulouse simon wants to capture toulouse and he feels this will end the war
西蒙·德·蒙福尔并自己宣称对该地区的主权。结果他在穆雷的一场大战中阵亡了。所以这种屠杀和恐怖感在不断升级。但总的来说，整个基督教世界的民众将其视为展示基督力量的一种有益的示范。因此，佩格在他的书《最圣洁的战争》的开篇，就对炼狱中出现的第一个幽灵进行了令人难以置信的描述：那是一个向小女孩显现的小男孩，他向这个女孩保证，没有什么比消灭阿尔比派更能取悦上帝了。而“阿尔比派”是当时用来称呼该地区异端的词，即“Albigois”。就这样，这种无休止的屠杀、无休止的焚烧田野持续了大约20年，直到最后，在1218年，西蒙·德·蒙福尔与困守图卢兹的雷蒙六世之间陷入了这种僵局。西蒙想要攻占图卢兹，他觉得这将结束战争
and simon vows that he will capture toulouse within a week and the following day the ladies and and the small girls of toulouse are busy working a kind of siege engine you know because it's all hands to the deck they fire it and it crashes into uh simon's head and he drops dead oh that's a nice ending i'm glad that he's dead tom i didn't i didn't care for him i have to say he's a terrifying man and with him gone everything kind of falls to pieces because his son amory is who inherits that you know simon simon de montfort the younger simon inherits his olddom of Leicester, which is why he's able to be the founder of English democracy. But Amory turns out to be
并且西蒙发誓他会在一周内攻占图卢兹，第二天，图卢兹的妇女和小女孩们正忙着操作某种攻城器械，你知道的，因为这是全员皆兵，她们发射了器械，它砸中了西蒙的头部，他当场倒地身亡。哦，这倒是个不错的结局。我很高兴他死了，汤姆，我可不喜欢他。我不得不说，他是个可怕的人。他一死，一切都土崩瓦解了，因为继承他爵位的是他的儿子阿毛里，你知道的，年轻的西蒙·德·蒙福尔继承了他父亲的莱斯特伯爵领地，这就是为什么他能够成为英国民主之父。但事实证明，阿毛里
absolutely useless, and he can't hold it together. And so the son of Philip II, the King of France, Louis, he is made of much sterner stuff. He much more of an enthusiast for for crusade than philip right and so in 1219 he does go down to this region and he conducts a siege of toulouse it's just about to fall then the 40 days are up and so louis feels that he's done his duty and so he goes back and so toulouse survives and raymond the sixth survives and raymond then dies in 1222, and his son, inevitably called Raymond, wants to bury him in a priory in Toulouse. But he can't because his dad is still excommunicated. And so the coffin with Raymond's body in it has to be left outside the priory church, where it is left for 200 years. 200 years 200 years yes and it it kind of you know it gets eaten you know the his
绝对是个废柴，他根本无法维持大局。因此，法兰克国王腓力二世的儿子路易，他可要坚强得多。他对十字军东征的热情远比腓力高得多，对吧？所以在1219年，他确实南下到了这个地区，并对图卢兹发动了围城战。眼看着它就要陷落，但40天期限已到，路易觉得自己已经尽到了职责，于是便回去了。因此图卢兹得以幸存，雷蒙六世也得以幸存。接着雷蒙在1222年去世，他的儿子（不可避免地也叫雷蒙）想把他安葬在图卢兹的一个修道院里。但他做不到，因为他父亲依然处于绝罚状态。所以装着雷蒙遗体的棺材不得不被放在修道院教堂外面，在那里一放就是200年。200年！200年，是的。而且它，你知道的，它被，你知道的，他的
body gets eaten by rats the coffin rots away and it all just completely vanishes so it's i mean it's a kind of another dimension of the horrible yeah so many gothic details in this story yes so ray 7th succeeds him uh he's he's very kind of vigorous and able, but he knows really that he's up against it because by this point, Philip II's son Louis has become Louis VIII. And he really, really is determined to kind of annex the whole region and bring it under directly under French rule. So 1224, Louis VIII accepts the lands that Anne-Marie de Montfort had inherited from his father and he takes them over. So these are now kind of property of the French crown. And two years after that, in 1226, he takes the cross. He leads a crusade, the largest crusade since 1209,
尸体被老鼠吃掉了，棺材也腐烂了，一切都彻底消失了。所以我的意思是，这是恐怖的又一个维度。是的，这个故事里有太多哥特式的细节了。是的，所以雷蒙七世继位了。他非常充满活力和能力，但他心里清楚，自己面对的是巨大的阻力，因为到了这个时候，腓力二世的儿子路易已经成为了路易八世。他真的、真的决心要兼并整个地区，将其置于法国的直接统治之下。因此在1224年，路易八世接受了阿毛里·德·蒙福尔从他父亲那里继承的土地，并将它们接管过来。所以这些现在成为了法兰克王室的财产。两年后的1226年，他十字架加身，发动了一场十字军东征，这是自1209年以来规模最大的一次十字军东征，
and he invades the Languedoc. And again, it looks as though it's all up for Raymond. But Louis VIII falls ill, and he is taken back in a litter to Paris. And most people attribute it to dysentery. But there is one courtier thinks that it's because Louis VIII is very pious that he hasn't been having enough sex. And so he introduces a courtesan into the, you know, the tent where Louis is wasting away. And Louis is said to have covered his private parts and told the prostitute, Madam, it shall not be.
并入侵了朗格多克。又一次，情况看起来雷蒙全完了。但路易八世病倒了，他被用担架抬回了巴黎。大多数人都把这归咎于痢疾。但有一位朝臣认为，这是因为路易八世过于虔诚，导致他没有足够的性生活。于是他把一名名妓带进了路易日渐消瘦的帐篷里。据说路易捂住了自己的下体，对妓女说：“夫人，万万不可。”
And he dies shortly afterwards. Which would be fair if he was wasting away. He's probably not in the mood. Quite, exactly. So 1228, Raymond VII finally kind of sues for peace. You know, he says, I give up. And 1229, peace treaty is signed in Paris. And this brings the war officially to an end.
不久后他便去世了。如果他是日渐消瘦的话，这倒也合情合理。他大概也没那个心情。完全正确，正是如此。所以在1228年，雷蒙七世终于求和了。你知道的，他说：“我认输。”1229年，和平条约在巴黎签署。这宣告了战争的正式结束。
And by its terms, Raymond remains the Count of Toulouse, but he loses a great eastern chunk of his territory, which goes to the French crown. The French crown has also grabbed Béziers Carcassonne. They keep that. Raymond's daughter, who's nine years old, a little girl called Joanne, is attributed to Louis' younger brother, a guy called Alphonse. And the stipulation is that their children will be the heirs of Raymond. So they will inherit
根据条约条款，雷蒙继续担任图卢兹伯爵，但他失去了领土的一大块东部区域，这部分归了法兰克王室。法兰克王室还夺取了贝济耶和卡尔卡松。他们保留了这些土地。雷蒙九岁的小女儿，一个叫琼的小女孩，被许配给了路易的弟弟，一个叫阿方斯的男子。条约规定他们的孩子将成为雷蒙的继承人。因此他们将继承
the lands of Toulouse. But the problem is that they don't have children. And so when Alphonse and Joanne both die in 1271, Toulouse as well passes to the French crown. And so it becomes part of the fabric of the kingdom of France. And the other term is that Raymond will continue to hunt out the heretics. And so even though the war has ended, the war against heresy hasn't. And I think that, you know, we should take a break. And definitely when we come back look at basically you know it's a question that you've been asking over again and i'm sure the listeners
图卢兹的土地。但问题是他们没有孩子。因此，当阿方斯和琼在1271年双双去世时，图卢兹也归入了法兰克王室。于是它成为了法兰克王国版图的一部分。另一个条款是雷蒙将继续搜捕异端。所以尽管战争已经结束，但针对异端的战争却没有结束。我认为，你知道的，我们应该休息一下。毫无疑问，当我们回来时，基本上要探讨一个你反复提出、我确信听众们
have been pondering it as well is you know you know if there is no heresy or no major heresy why are they hurling themselves into the flames and perhaps talk about that okay i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
也在苦思冥想的问题，那就是：如果没有异端或主要的异端，为什么他们会自愿跳进烈火中呢？或许我们可以讨论一下这个。好的，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦花絮，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客，
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. with a sudden upwelling of reverence robert langdon fell to his knees for a moment he thought he heard tom holland's voice the wisdom of the ages whispering up from the chasms of the earth that's what it feels like for me tom listening to you talk about the cathars those are of course the final lines of the da vinci code one of the great texts of 2003 of the 21st century perhaps even of all time said nobody ever i'm sure didn't i'm sure dan brown must have said that i think i'm sure he's not an immodest man is he he might well say that other books angels and demons inferno are superior. As he's honed his craft.
以及提前获得现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。“随着一股突如其来的敬畏之情涌上心头，罗伯特·兰登双膝跪地。有一瞬间，他以为自己听到了汤姆·赫兰德的声音，那是来自大地深渊的、低语着历代智慧的声音。对我来说，听你谈论卡特派，就是这种感觉。”这些当然是《达·芬奇密码》的最后几句台词，那是2003年、21世纪甚至有史以来最伟大的文本之一——没人这么说过。我确信没有，我确信丹·布朗肯定没说过这话。我想我确信他不是一个不谦虚的人吧？他很可能会这么说。《天使与魔鬼》《地狱》是更优秀的作品。随着他不断打磨自己的技艺。
So, Tom, we started with The Da Vinci Code. We've actually found our way into, I think, a much stranger and more interesting story. This is the story of the Albigensian Crusade. Completely agree. It is an extraordinary, fascinating story. So we ended with the end of the war. The counts of Toulouse have become belittled. I mean, they have less territory,
所以，汤姆，我们从《达芬奇密码》开始。实际上，我们发现自己走进了一个陌生得多、也更有趣的故事里。这就是阿尔比十字军东征的故事。完全同意。这是一个非凡的、引人入胜的故事。所以我们以战争的结束收尾。图卢兹伯爵们的势力被削弱了。我是说，他们拥有的领地变少了，
their French crown has got more territory. So you could look at this and say, well, this is just basically a land grab. But for the fact that you ended by saying that the Counts of Toulouse were told they had to continue fighting heresy and rooting out heresy, which suggests that it's not just a fig leaf, there's something very substantial going on there. And how is that war on heresy this was supposed to be all about? What's been going on with that? So, I mean, right the way through, I've been saying that by the lights of the Roman church, there are lots of people in this region who do count as heretics. And the particular focus is this notion that there are people called boni homines, the good men, the good women, who can attain a holiness that is equal to or greater than that of priests.
法国王室获得的领地则变多了。所以你可能会看着这一切心想，好吧，这基本上就是一场土地强占。但问题在于，你最后提到图卢兹伯爵们被告知，他们必须继续与异端战斗并铲除异端，这表明这不仅仅是一个借口，其中有非常实质性的东西在发生。那么，这场本应旨在打击异端的战争究竟怎么样了？这方面的情况如何？所以，我的意思是，从头到尾我一直在说，按照罗马教会的标准，这个地区有很多人确实算得上异端。其中一个特别的焦点是这样一种观念：这里有一些被称为“良善之人”（boni homines，即“好男人”、“好女人”）的人，他们能够达到一种等同于或高于神职人员的圣洁。
And this is absolute anathema to the Roman church. The division between laity and priests is fundamental to it, both because they have a very elevated sense of the role of the priesthood, but also because it's the priests and the clerics and the scholars who are responsible for instructing the vast mass of the Christian people in Christian doctrine. And so therefore, people who resist that are to be condemned. But for people in the Al-Bijwa, in this region that is being targeted by the crusade, do not see themselves as heretics. They see the invaders as heretics. And that's not just because they are defending beliefs that they
这对于罗马教会来说是绝对的诅咒。俗民与神职人员之间的分歧是至关重要的，一方面是因为他们对神职人员的角色有着极高的尊崇，另一方面是因为正是神职人员、教士和学者们负责向广大基督徒群众传授基督教教义。因此，抗拒这一点的人理应受到谴责。但是对于阿尔比（Albi）地区、这个成为十字军东征目标的地区的人们来说，他们并不觉得自己是异端。他们把入侵者视为异端。这不仅是因为他们在捍卫自己
hold. It's also that those beliefs structure their entire way of life. So we were saying how you become a good man or a good woman because you practice courtesy. You display good manners. And this courtesy and this sense of good manners is important because life in this region is so tough. People are scrabbling over so much. And so if you tell people that, you know, good men or good women are heretics, then in a sense, you're knocking away the props that sustain not just people's relationship with God, which is obviously incredibly important to them, but also their ability to interact with their fellow human beings. And I think that
所持有的信仰。还因为这些信仰构建了他们的整个生活方式。所以我们之前说过，你如何成为一个“好男人”或“好女人”呢？因为你践行礼节。你展现出良好的教养。这种礼节和良好的教养意识之所以重要，是因为这个地区的生存环境太艰难了。人们为了微薄的生存资料苦苦挣扎。因此，如果你告诉人们，你知道的，“好男人”或“好女人”是异端，那么在某种意义上，你就是在摧毁那些支撑人们与上帝关系的支柱——上帝对他们而言显然极其重要——同时也在摧毁他们与同胞交往的能力。我认为
we talked about how the Cathars in the 21st century have a kind of very positive image that their new age, Kate Moss's book Labyrinth, cast them as feminists. This idea that there were female priests when the Catholic church obviously did not allow women and still doesn't allow women to become priests. And this idea that the Cathars had female priests derives from the notion that there were good women as well as good men. But I think that when you look more closely at who is allowed to become a good woman, you see the way in which the understanding of this institution, this idea that there are people who are of both sex who are capable of attaining a particular kind of closeness to God, closeness to Christ, the way that it actually has a kind of
我们之前讨论过21世纪的卡特里派（Cathars）如何拥有某种非常积极的形象，他们的“新时代”色彩、凯特·莫斯的书《迷宫》（Labyrinth）将他们塑造成了女权主义者。这种观点认为，当时存在女神职人员，而天主教会显然不允许女性——而且现在仍然不允许女性——成为神职人员。卡特里派拥有女神职人员的这种观点，源于“好女人”和“好男人”并存的概念。但我觉得，当你更仔细地审视谁被允许成为一个“好女人”时，你就会发现这种制度的理解方式——即存在着不分性别、都能够达到某种特定程度的与上帝和基督亲近的人——实际上具有某种
social role. Because you can become a good woman if you're a girl before puberty. Yeah. And you can become a good woman again if you are a widow, you know, if you're a matron, if your childbearing years are over. But in between, you know, the moment you hit puberty as a girl, you're married off. And the reason for that is that this is a society in which virginity and female chastity, like everything else, fields, orchards, vineyards, or whatever, has to be tightly controlled because competition is so ferocious. So actually, it's the very opposite of a feminist paradise. And so there is an absolute chasm of incomprehension between the
社会角色。因为如果你是一个处于青春期之前的女孩，你可以成为一个“好女人”。是的。而如果你是一个寡妇，你知道的，如果你是一位贵妇，如果你生育孩子的年华已经过去，你也可以再次成为一个“好女人”。但在那之间，你知道的，当女孩一到青春期，你就会被嫁出去。原因在于，这是一个将童贞和女性贞洁——就像其他一切一样，比如田野、果园、葡萄园或任何东西——必须进行严格控制的社会，因为竞争实在是太残酷了。所以实际上，这完全不是什么女权主义的天堂。因此，在
Crusaders and the people who they are attacking. And I think that people are willing to die because they are standing up not only for their very, very devoutly held understanding of God and Christ and their faith, but also because that understanding of their faith is interwoven in their whole way of life. So R.A. Moore, the great historian of this Christian revolution, and specifically, you know, he wrote the War on heresy about this this whole process he makes a really intriguing parallel with the witchcraft panic in the 17th century yeah and so he writes the yawning chasm of mutual incomprehension between occitanians so the people of of the midi and outsiders makes nonsense of the natural questions of how many heretics there were and what proportion of the population supported them to ask these questions is rather like asking how many witches there were in europe on the eve of the great witch craze these are not labels where you can divide people into sheep and goats and say
十字军和他们所攻击的人民之间，存在着一道绝对无法逾越的理解鸿沟。我认为人们愿意去死，是因为他们不仅在坚守他们极其虔诚的对上帝、基督和信仰的理解，还因为对信仰的这种理解已经深深交织在他们的整个生活方式中。因此，这一基督教革命的伟大历史学家R·A·穆尔（R.A. Moore）——特别是他曾就整个过程撰写过《对异端的战争》（The War on Heresy）——将这与17世纪的猎巫恐慌作了一个非常耐人寻味的类比。是的，所以他写道：奥克西坦尼亚人（即米迪地区的人）与局外人之间那种充满哈欠般巨大的相互不理解的鸿沟，让“当时有多少异端、多大比例的人口支持他们”这类自然之问变得毫无意义。提出这些问题，就像是在问大猎巫前夕的欧洲到底有多少女巫一样。这些并不是能把人简单分成绵羊和山羊并说出
here's the list of witches because it was so culturally conditioned and accusations are reflecting so many different factors absolutely but also what is happening and again this is where the parallel with the kind of the the sudden kind of upsurge of anxiety about witches is so interesting, that the backdrop to the Albigensian Crusade is a desire to define heresy much more tightly. So Innocent III, the great Pope who launched the Crusade in 1215, he holds another council at the Lateran, so the fourth Lateran council. And it's a confession of faith. It's about institutionalizing measures to improve the governance of the church, a better education of the clergy, better education of the laity. This is when the obligation is imposed on the laity to confess to a priest at least once every year.
“这是女巫名单”的标签，因为这一切都带有深刻的文化制约，而且指控反映了太多不同的因素。绝对如此；但同时发生的——这也是为什么将之与突然涌现的对女巫的焦虑进行类比如此有趣——是阿尔比十字军东征的背景，乃是一种更紧密地定义异端的渴望。因此，英诺森三世（Innocent III）这位在1215年发动十字军东征的伟大教皇，在拉特兰又主持了一次会议，即第四次拉特兰公会议。这是一场信仰告白。它旨在将各项旨在改善教会治理、更好地教育神职人员以及更好地教育俗民的措施制度化。正是在这个时候，俗民被强加了一项义务：每年至少向神职人员告解一次。
So it's when the practice of confession is introduced it also starts to target not just heretics but also jews and muslims who if they're living in christian lands are obliged to wear separate clothing so that the divisions between christians heretics jews muslims are being made absolutely specific and moore says that um like all sweeping and visionary measures of administrative reform the implementation of the degrees would entail vastly increased responsibilities and opportunities for the administrators themselves. Later in the fourth was a charter for the clericalization of society so it's an expression of the fear that the educated, the scholarly, the clerical, the academic, you might say, have for the rustic
所以正是在此时引入了告解的习俗；它开始针对的不仅是异端，还有犹太人和穆斯林——如果他们生活在基督教土地上，他们被迫穿戴不同的服饰，以便将基督徒、异端、犹太人和穆斯林之间的界限划分得绝对具体。穆尔说，嗯，就像所有大刀阔斧、富有远见的行政改革措施一样，这些法令的实施将为管理者本身带来大大增加的责任和机遇。第四次拉特兰会议是社会教士化的宪章，因此它表达了一种恐惧：受过教育的、饱学诗书的、神职的、学术的人（你可以这么说），对粗野的、
and the backward and the uneducated. Oh, my word, Tom, this is sort of, every institution needs to have its own sensitivity consultants. The idea that a revolution, an intellectual or cultural revolution needs administrators and bureaucrats, and that that opens up all sorts of opportunities. That'll be familiar to anybody who's read about stalinism or any great revolution and so then the question is well you know you were asking how how is it that this kind of polarized sense that the heretics themselves come to have that that persuades them to hurl themselves into the fire how does that kind of sharpen over the course of the war and its aftermath. And the Cistercians, so Amalric, who is the Cistercian abbot, the Cistercians are kind of intellectual shop troops for most of this period.
落后的、未受教育的人所怀有的恐惧。天哪，汤姆，这简直是……每个机构都需要有自己的敏感度顾问。认为一场革命——一场知识或文化革命——需要行政人员和官僚，而这会开启各种各样的机遇，这对于任何读过斯大林主义或任何伟大革命历史的人来说都会感到似曾相识。那么问题来了，你知道的，你之前问过：这种两极化的意识——异端自己逐渐产生的这种意识，如何说服他们将自己投入火中？这种意识在战争及其余波的过程中是如何变得如此尖锐的？西多会（Cistercians）——也就是身为西多会修道院院长的阿马尔里克（Amalric）——西多会在这段时期的绝大部分时间里，就像是知识界的突击队。
And they are constructing this ever kind of more totalizing sense of there being this heretic church full of the echoes of ancient heresies. And so this is really sharpening this idea that these heretics are part of a kind of ancient continuum. So this is when all the stuff about dualism starts to be written up. This hadn't been mentioned before the war. Oh, how fascinating. So the Manichaeanism. So the Manichaeanism is being written in. This is where you start to get the first mentions that they believe that Mary Magdalene was Christ's concubine. And they put that in presumably because it's so shocking.
他们正在构建一种日益全面化的感知，即存在着一个充满古代异端回响的异端教会。因此，这确实使这样一种观点变得更加尖锐：这些异端是一个某种古代延续体的一部分。所以，所有关于二元论的说法都是在这个时候被写进去的。这在战前是没有被提及过的。哦，太迷人了。所以摩尼教（Manichaeanism）被写入其中。正是在这里，你开始听到最初的提及，说他们相信抹大拉的玛丽亚是基督的情妇。他们把这一点写进去，大概是因为这太令人震惊了。
But also because it's an ancient heresy. Right. So they're reading it up in their ancient accounts and putting it in. But before this point, people aren't talking about this being an issue. No. Fascinating. So this is something that the Cistercians are starting to construct. But also they're not just making it up because they're also speaking
但也因为这是一个古老的异端。没错。所以他们从古代的记载中查阅并将其写入。但在这一点之前，人们并不认为这是一个问题。不。太迷人了。所以这是西多会开始构建的东西。但同时，他们并非凭空捏造，因为他们也在与
to the heretics whom they're opposing and they report to the heretics that the heretics say that the roman church is a den of thieves and the harlot spoken of in the book of revelation and that has the kind of the ring of truth because the idea that the roman church is the whore of babylon is a standard trope for all kinds of heretics right the way into the Protestant Reformation. This is combined with the destruction, not just of the beliefs of the good men and the good women, but their whole way of life. Everything that has given structure and meaning to their life is being eradicated. And so by the end of the war, the few good men and good women who survive are, you know, they're refugees. They're hiding in woods, hiding in cellars,
他们所反对的异端对话，他们向外界报告说异端声称罗马教会是一个贼窝，是《启示录》中所说的娼妇；这听起来有一定的真实性，因为“罗马教会是巴比伦妓女”的观点是各种异端的一贯修辞，一直延续到新教改革时期。这与对“好男人”和“好女人”信仰的摧毁结合在一起，不仅是信仰，还有他们的整个生活方式。所有赋予他们生命结构和意义的事物都被根除了。因此，到战争结束时，少数幸存的“好男人”和“好女人”，你知道的，他们成了难民。他们躲在树林里、藏在地窖里，
looking for refuge wherever they can find it. And their attempt to kind of maintain the traditions and the rituals that had previously structured their life, it's kind of almost pathetic. You know, they're trying to keep alive something that is plainly destroyed it's kind of kind of tragic expression of nostalgia for a way of life that has entirely gone and they do you know they do find strongholds so monseguer which we've talked about throughout this series you know that's the last of the strongholds yeah famously yeah and they that you know great number get burnt it's the last great holocaust and i think that by that point what is interesting is that many of the heretics seem to have internalized the accusations leveled against them by the by their enemies and kind of
四处寻找避难所。他们试图维持那些曾赋予他们生活结构的传统和仪式的努力，几乎显得有些可怜。你知道的，他们试图让一些明显已经被摧毁的东西继续存活下去，这是一种对已经彻底消逝的生活方式的怀旧的、近乎悲剧性的表达。而且他们确实（你知道的）找到了据点，比如我们在整个系列中讨论过的蒙塞居（Montségur），你知道的，那是最后的据点，是的，众所周知的，是的。他们（你知道的）有大量的人被烧死，这是最后的大屠杀。我认为到那个时候，有趣的是，许多异端似乎已经内化了敌人对他们的指控，并且某种程度上
come to believe them oh that's interesting so in other words those accusations probably had a tiny tiny grain of i don't think they had any grain of truth i mean lots of them had no grain of truth at all you don't think they had any grain of truth but that people have started playing the part well so so there are some documents again and this is quite kind of Da Vinci Code and Holy Blood and Holy Grail. There are some documents that were found in the 17th century that claim to have been written by Cathars, heretics, whatever you want to call them, in the aftermath of the Crusade that do talk about dualism. And so there's much debate among historians about whether these are authentic or whether they are uh protestant fabrications but i think both moore and peg think that they are authentic and they both argue that these are expressions of the way in which you know the heretics have been so shattered so destroyed all the kind of underpinnings of everything that they
开始相信这些指控。哦，这太有趣了。换句话说，那些指控可能包含哪怕微乎其微的……我不认为它们包含任何真实的成分。我的意思是，其中很多根本没有一丝真实的成分。你认为它们没有任何真实的成分，但人们开始扮演这个角色？好吧，所以……有一些文件，又是那种非常像《达芬奇密码》以及《圣血与圣杯》的东西。17世纪发现了一些文件，声称是十字军东征之后由卡特里派、异端，或者无论你想怎么称呼他们的人所写，这些文件确实谈到了二元论。因此，历史学家们对于这些文件究竟是真实的还是
believed you know for generations have been destroyed that in a sense they're trying to hold on to a sense of their difference by by kind of basically you know they've got stockholm syndrome they're they're agreeing with what their accusers are saying and that takes us on to how you know it's not just a kind of military campaign that is being fought in the wake of the uh of the crusade to kind of snuff out the last outposts of this you also have the figures of inquisitors and it's not the inquisition right that's a 16th century phenomenon but it's it's inquisitors and these inquisitors are again absolutely an expression of this kind of intellectual revolution that is running concurrently with the broader institutional revolution in this period. Because what the inquisitors are doing is buying into the rediscovery of the text
新教徒伪造的有着激烈的争论，但我认为穆尔和佩格（Peg）都认为它们是真实的，并且他们都辩称，这些文件表达了这样一种方式：你知道的，异端们已经被彻底粉碎、彻底毁灭了，他们几代人以来所信仰的一切的基石都被摧毁了，因此在某种意义上，他们试图通过基本上……你知道的，他们得了斯德哥尔摩综合征，他们同意了指控他们的人所说的话，以此来抓住一丝与众不同的感觉。这把我们带到了下一步：你知道的，在十字军东征之后，为了扑灭异端的最后据点而进行的不仅仅是一场军事战役，你还会看到宗教裁判所（inquisitors）的身影。这并非审判庭（the Inquisition）本身，对吧？那是16世纪的产物，但这是宗教裁判官（inquisitors）。而这些宗教裁判官同样绝对是这场知识革命的产物，这场革命与这一时期更广泛的体制革命同时进行。因为宗教裁判官们正在接受对文本的重新发现——
of Aristotle, the great Greek philosopher, whose works had been found in Toledo when that was conquered from the Saracens in the 11th century and brought from Constantinople. And by 1200, all his works have been translated into Latin. And what Aristotle offers is an emphasis on reason. So that, in other words, the inquisitors, rather than relying on kind of ordeals, say the Monty Python stereotype that you kind of duck them or ordeals by combat or that kind of thing. They're saying, no, Aristotle shows us how we can use reason to penetrate to the nature of heresy, to examine it. And the obligation is enshrined both by the Fourth Lateran Council, but also by kind of various institutions that move into this region to try and crush the heresy, that the obligation is laid on to question and to interrogate and to
亚里士多德的文本，这位伟大的希腊哲学家，他的著作在11世纪托莱多从萨拉森人手中被征服时在那里被发现，并从君士坦丁堡被带回。到1200年，他的所有著作都已被翻译成拉丁文。而亚里士多德所强调的是理性。换句话说，宗教裁判官们不再依赖神明裁判（ordeals）——比如巨蟒剧团（Monty Python）式的刻板印象，即把人浸入水中，或是决斗裁判之类的事情。他们说：“不，亚里士多德向我们展示了如何利用理性来深入异端的本质，去检验它。”第四次拉特兰公会议以及进驻该地区试图粉碎异端的各种机构都确立了这一义务：即必须进行盘问、审讯、
obtain evidence and to evaluate it and aristotle is the great model for this now dominic you'll be pleased to know that the guy who takes the lead in this yeah is a man who shares your name dominic good man uh dominic canis the hound of the lord dominic that's what people call me something they call me the hound of dacre well so so this uh this previous dominic uh he's a Spaniard, Dominic de Guthman. Yeah. He'd taken a big lead before the crusade in touring the region, combating heretics. He's still doing it throughout the crusade.
获取证据并进行评估，而亚里士多德就是这方面的伟大楷模。多米尼克（Dominic），你可能会高兴地知道，在这方面带头的人，是的，是一个与你同名的人——好人多米尼克。嗯，“狗魔”多米尼克（Dominic canis），主的猎犬，多米尼克，人们就是这么叫我的。有人叫我达克雷的猎犬。好吧……所以，这个前多米尼克……他是一个西班牙人，多米尼克·德·古斯曼（Dominic de Guzman）。是的。他在十字军东征之前就在巡游该地区、打击异端方面发挥了带头作用。他在整个十字军东征期间也一直在这样做。
So there's this story reported by Peg that he goes to a town that's been sacked by the crusaders and there's a survivor there dominic is preaching trying to persuade the heretics to convert and one of the survivors suddenly gets attacked by a demonic cat that leaps up and hurls itself and kind of you know savages him um and this is taken as a sign that the man is a heretic and so he gets burned so this is the the world in which dominic is operating dominic is a flagellant is he tom i'm sorry to say he does yes so he he whips himself three times every night once for himself once for sinners and once for penitence in purgatory you know the key thing is that he is motivated by compassion for the heretics listeners may sound think this is this is insane to say this he's clearly a
所以佩格（Peg）报道了一个故事：他去了一个被十字军洗劫的城镇，那里有一个幸存者。多米尼克正在讲道，试图说服异端皈依，而其中一个幸存者突然遭到了一只恶魔猫的袭击，那只猫跳扑过来，猛烈地攻击他、撕咬他。这被视为此人是异端的一个征兆，于是他被烧死了。所以这就是多米尼克所处的世界。多米尼克是一个苦行僧（flagellant）吗，汤姆？我很遗憾地告诉你，是的。所以他每晚鞭打自己三次：一次为自己，一次为罪人，一次为炼狱中的忏悔者。你知道，关键在于，他是出于对异端的同情而受到驱使的。听众可能会觉得这听起来太疯狂了，他显然是一个
psychopath i don't think he is so it was said of him that god had given him a special grace to weep for sinners for the wretched and the afflicted he is really really keen to redeem the heretics from satan to bring them to god as he sees it to bring them to christ and so he to do this he establishes um an order of, of fratres in Latin, which comes to be the order, first order of friars. Francis of Assisi has also established an order of friars at the same time. And the point of the friars for Dominic is that they can provide a kind, you know, they are rivals to the good men. So he knows that the heretics he wants to convert admire the good men as models of asceticism, of good behavior, people who are kind of not complicit in the institutional frameworks of the church. And so he establishes the friars as something that could perhaps kind of appeal to the heretics.
精神病患者。我不认为他是。人们曾这样评价他：上帝赐予了他一种特殊的恩典，能为罪人、为不幸者和受苦者哭泣。他是真的很想把异端从撒旦手中拯救出来，按照他的看法，把他们带向上帝，把他们带向基督。为此，他创立了拉丁语中的“fratres”修会，这后来成为了第一代托钵修会（friars）。亚西西的方济各（Francis of Assisi）当时也建立了一个托钵修会。对多米尼克来说，托钵修会的意义在于，它们可以提供一种……你知道的，它们是“好男人”的竞争对手。所以他知道，他想要皈依的异端崇拜那些“好男人”，将其视为苦行和良好行为的楷模，这些人与教会的体制框架没有共谋关系。因此，他将托钵修会建立为某种可能对异端有吸引力的存在。
So they have no property. They live by begging. And they're not like monks because they're not retreating from the world. Right. to interrogate and educate and recover the heretics for the church. And this kind of dual approach throughout the 13th century into the 14th century of smoking out heretic strongholds and inquisitors kind of in a loving, God, you know, they see themselves as doing this for love. I will have you whipped and burned out of love yeah well i mean we're so kind of hostile to the whole idea of it but for inquisitors then they don't want to see heretics burnt if a heretic is burnt then it's failure it's like how i feel when i write a bad review. I don't enjoy doing it, but I'm doing it for the writer's own good.
所以他们没有财产。他们靠乞讨为生。他们不像修道士，因为他们没有隐退于世。没错。……去审讯、教育异端并为教会挽回他们。这种双重方法贯穿了13世纪到14世纪，一方面是烟熏火燎地搜捕异端据点，另一方面是宗教裁判官们以一种充满爱的方式——上帝啊，你知道的，他们认为自己这样做是出于爱：“我出于爱鞭打你、把你烧死。”是的。好吧，我的意思是，我们对这种做法的整个理念感到如此反感，但对于当时的宗教裁判官来说，他们并不希望看到异端被烧死。如果一个异端被烧死了，那就意味着失败。这就像我写了一篇糟糕的评论时的感觉一样。我并不喜欢这么做，但我这么做是为了作者本人好。
And listeners may say, well, this is insane. But I suppose, again, to update it, maybe it's people who are trying to persuade people not to be racist. Going out there to persuade people not to be racist. And you feel compassion for racistsists you want to redeem them you want to i don't know how many people would be convinced by this analogy i think it's a very precise analogy and i think it's the best way to you know not just instinctively kind of despise the dominicans as bigots because i think it's much more complicated than that. But that whole thing that obviously, you know, I said for lots of people since the Middle Ages,
听众可能会说，这太疯狂了。但我想，同样地，如果把它更新一下，也许就像那些试图说服人们不要种族歧视的人。走出去说服人们不要种族歧视。你对种族主义者感到同情，你想拯救他们，你想……我不知道有多少人会被这个类比说服。我认为这是一个非常精确的类比，而且我认为这是避免以下情况的最好方法：不仅是出于本能地将多明我会修士（Dominicans）视为偏执狂，因为我认为情况要复杂得多。但整件事显然，正如我所说，对于中世纪以来的很多人来说，
this is a terrible story. And, you know, it kind of highlights why I think the whole idea of the Cathars has been so popular, is that it kind of, you know, it reinforces the conceit of Catholics that the Catholic Church was in possession of the truth and that there were enemies of the Catholic Church. And to that extent, the crusade was justified. And likewise to Protestants or to Voltaire or, you know, right the way into the kind of the present age, new age people, whatever. It kind of demonstrates that religion is a terrible thing or whatever. I wanted to ask a quick question. How much does our romanticization of the Cathars,
这是一个可怕的故事。你知道的，它突显了为什么卡特里派的整个概念会如此受欢迎，因为它……你知道的，它强化了天主教徒的一种自负：即天主教会掌握着真理，而天主教会存在着敌人。从这个意义上讲，十字军东征是正义的。同样，对新教徒、伏尔泰，或者你知道的，一直到现今的新时代人群等等来说，它也证明了宗教是一件可怕的事情，诸如此类。我想问一个简短的问题：我们对卡特里派的浪漫化，
our invention of the Cathars, if you like, the Cathars were, as it were, invented in the Middle Ages, but then our reinvention of them, how much does that owe to Protestantism? The Protestants wanted to see the Catholic Church as repressive and burning people. And they also wanted to believe that there had always been a resistance. Well, I think it's really telling that I mentioned Charles Schmitt, the French scholar who in the mid-19th century writes the book, which has identified these heretics as Cathars, from which the, you know, the sense of them as, inverted commas, Cathars derives. I think that's absolutely true. So there's a really, I mean, I think there's a really interesting parallel here with what happens in the wake of the French
我们对卡特里派的“发明”——如果你愿意这么说的话，卡特里派可以说是在中世纪被发明的，但随后是我们对他们的“再发明”——这在多大程度上要归功于新教？新教徒希望看到天主教会具有压迫性并且把人烧死。他们还希望相信一直存在着某种抵抗力量。嗯，我认为非常说明问题的是，我之前提到的法国学者夏尔·施密特（Charles Schmidt），他在19世纪中期写了一本书，正是这本书将这些异端识别为卡特里派，倒号里的“卡特里派”概念也由此而来。我认为这绝对是真的。所以，我的意思是，我认为这里有一个非常有趣的类比，类比于法国大革命之后发生的事情。
Revolution. The French Revolution in so many ways is, although it's repudiating institutional Christianity and specifically the Catholic Church, it's so imbued with Christian assumptions. And exactly like the medieval church, the Roman church, it wants to wash the whole world clean of all kinds of sins and horrors and evils and it sees that those who are opposing them as being evil and the representative figures in the french revolutionary wars who embody this are the royalists of the vendee which is the region of france that is very very you know it's basically it's the same kind of region where the Great Crusade had been fought against heresy. Yeah, in the West Coast, Vendée. And in 1794, the leader of the revolutionary armies that are going to attack the counter-revolutionaries in the Vendée, you know, they're sweeping in.
法国革命在很多方面——尽管它在公开否认制度化的基督教特别是天主教会——却深深浸透了基督教的假设。而且就像中世纪教会、罗马教会一样，它想要洗净整个世界上所有的罪恶、恐怖和邪恶，它认为那些反对他们的人是邪恶的，在法国大革命战争中体现这一点的代表性人物是旺代（Vendée）的保皇党人。旺代是法国的一个地区，非常非常……你知道的，它基本上和当年针对异端进行伟大十字军东征的地区是同一个地方。是的，在西海岸，旺代。在1794年，进攻旺代反革命分子的革命军领袖，你知道的，他们席卷而来。
And there's this problem about how do you identify revolutionaries and how do you identify counter revolutionaries? And the general says to his men, spare with your bayonets all the inhabitants you encounter along the way. I know there may be a few patriots in the reason. It matters not. We must sacrifice all. And that, of course, is very, very like. God will know his own. God will know his own.
这里存在一个问题：你如何识别革命者，又如何识别反革命者？于是将军对他的手下说：“用你们的刺刀放过一路上遇到的所有居民。我知道这个地区可能还有几个爱国者。这没关系。我们必须牺牲所有人。”当然，这非常非常像……“上帝自有辨识”。上帝自有辨识。
Yeah. know his own god will know his own yeah i think it unsettles any idea we might have that the enlightenment or the revolution the french revolution is somehow less murderous less sanguinary less oppressive than the medieval church is that in the vonday you have no equivalent of the dominicans the dominicans are consciously trying to apply a scalpel. You know, they want to kill as few people as possible in the cause of healing this diseased flesh. Whereas the French revolutionaries have no time for that, because they feel that they're on the right side of history, and that those who are on the story of the albigensian crusade is unsettling because it's not just about how people in the middle ages were barbarous and savage and cruel it's about us as well yeah you know it's anachronistic to talk about progressives in the middle ages but if there were progressives in the medieval context it would be you know the roman church because they have a sense you know that it is their ambition to cleanse to purify to uplift to educate the vast
是的。上帝自有辨识，上帝自有辨识。是的，我认为这动摇了我们可能有的某种观念：即启蒙运动或法国大革命、法国大革命不知何故比中世纪教会更不嗜杀、更不血腥、更不具压迫性。因为在旺代，你找不到任何类似于多明我会修士的东西。多明我会修士是在有意识地试图使用手术刀。你知道的，为了治愈这些病态的肌肉，他们想尽可能少杀人。而法国国民则没有这种耐心，因为他们觉得他们站在历史正确的一边，而那些站在历史错误一边的人……阿尔比十字军东征的故事之所以令人不安，不仅是因为它关乎中世纪的人民如何野蛮、残酷，还关乎我们自己。
mass of the ignorant and bring them into the light and that essentially has always been you know that's the mission of the protestants it's the mission of the french revolutionaries it's the mission of progressives today so i think that that is why the story is so powerful and so unsettling, because it's not just about bloodlines of Christ, but it's also not about something that can be parked and sneered at as some example of medieval superstition and backwardness, because we are the heirs of those crusaders. We're not the heirs of the Cathars. Craigie, what a richly interesting and strange story, Tom. That was absolutely fascinating. Thank you for that. That was brilliant. I really enjoyed that. I knew nothing
是的，你知道的，用中世纪的语境来谈论“进步人士”是时代的错置，但如果中世纪的语境中真的有进步人士，那大概就是罗马教会了，因为他们有一种意识——你知道的——他们的雄心是净化、纯洁、提升、教育广大无知的群众，并把他们带入光明之中。从本质上讲，这一直以来都是……你知道的，这是新教徒的使命，这是法国革命者的使命，也是今天进步人士的使命。所以我觉得这就是为什么这个故事如此有力量且如此令人不安，因为它不仅关乎基督的血脉，而且它也不是那种可以被搁置一旁、当作中世纪迷信和落后事例来嘲笑的东西，因为我们正是那些十字军战士的继承者。我们不是卡特里派的继承者。克雷吉（Craigie），这是一个极其有趣且奇异的故事，汤姆。这绝对太迷人了。非常感谢你讲这个。这太精彩了。我真的很喜欢。其实在开始之前我一无所知
about the Cathars really before we started. And I have to say I've learned an enormous amount. But what I'm going to do now is I'm going to return to my reading of Dan Brown's wonderful novel, The Da Vinci Code. Now, if you listened from the very beginning, from the first episode, you will know that we left it hanging with that moment when the curator, renowned curator, Jacques Saunier, was lying under a painting with an albino monk breathing down his neck. And, Tom, I know you know what happens next. I can't actually remember.
关于卡特里派的知识。我必须说我学到了极其丰富的内容。但我现在要做的是，我要回去继续阅读丹·布朗（Dan Brown）的精彩小说《达芬奇密码》。现在，如果你从一开始、从第一集就一直在听，你就会知道我们当时留了一个悬念：馆长、著名的馆长雅克·索尼耶（Jacques Saunier）正躺在一幅画下面，一个白化病修道士在他的脖子后面喘着粗气。汤姆，我知道你知道接下来发生了什么。其实我记不太清了。
You said it was one of the great reading experiences of your life. That's what I remember you saying. I've moved on. I can't actually remember the plot. He gets kind of put in a pentangle or something, doesn't he? Yes. Like Leonardo da Vinci's Vitruvian Man. He's trapped in the grand gallery of the Louvre.
你说过这是你一生中最棒的阅读体验之一。我记得你是这么说的。我已经翻篇了。我其实记不清情节了。他被放进了一个五角星之类的形状里，对吧？是的。就像达芬奇的《维特鲁威人》（Vitruvian Man）一样。他被困卢浮宫的大画廊里。
And all I will say is, wincing in pain, he summoned all of his faculties and strength. The desperate task before him he knew would require every remaining second of his life. That's how I feel about this podcast. Goodbye, everybody. It's goodbye for me, and it's goodbye from 48-year-old man, Dominic Sandbrook. Goodbye. Goodbye.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
我只想说：他强忍着痛苦，调动了全身的官能和力量。他知道，摆在他面前的绝望任务需要他生命中的每一秒钟。这就是我对这个播客的感受。大家再见。对我来说是再见，对48岁的男子多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）来说也是再见。再见。Goodbye.com。那是restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的良药。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及抢先购买现场门票的权益，请前往 rest 本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。